MALE SPEAKER: Good afternoon.
It's my great
pleasure to introduce
a good friend and former
neighbor Steve LeVine.
Just to make sure
we're on the same page,
this is Steve LeVine the
author, not the Steve Levine
the record producer, who
worked with the Beach
Boys, The Clash, and of course
who could forget Culture Club.
He is not, of course, Steve
Levine the RE/MAX real estate
agent, nor Steve Levine the
professor of soil and waste
resources at Wisconsin.
Go Badgers.
Or even the owner of Steve
LeVine's Exotic Dancers
in Scottsdale, Arizona.
No, we are here to
listen to Steve LeVine
the author, the war
correspondent, the Washington
correspondent for the
online news zine courts,
the adjunct professor
at Georgetown,
and dare I say, the
intellectual Steve LeVine.
I believe I introduced
him the first time
he spoke here back in
2007 when he talked
to us about his first book,
"The Glory and the Oil,"
the story of how the oil
industry came into being.
In a strange way, or
perhaps not so strange,
this book about batteries
is very closely related
to some would even say
the same logical successor
to the first book.
I'm anxious to hear more about
this very relevant topic.
So without much
further ado-- wait,
did I mention that he was
some sort of senior fellow
at the Hoover Institute?
No, I guess it was
just a visiting
fellow at the international
studies at Stanford.
OK.
I also know from
your Wikipedia page
that you're the Future Tense
Fellow at the New America
Foundation.
Future Tense Fellow.
Kind of makes it hard to
talk about history, isn't it?
Anyways, without much
more further ado,
I'd like to welcome back
to Google Steve LeVine.
STEVE LEVINE: Thanks.
Thanks, [? Carl ?].
Good afternoon.
Thanks very much, again,
for having me at Google.
It is true that there are
a lot of Steve LeVines
out there, including in
Bethesda, Maryland, where
I live.
And there's a Steve
LeVine who has
the slot at the dry cleaner,
at the coffee shop, and so on.
Google, in fact, has let
the other Steve LeVine have
the good Steve LeVine
email address, leaving me
with stevlevine.
I hope after this, you guys
could do something about that.
Why did I write a
book about batteries
is the first question that
I got the whole way along
and that I continue to hear.
I came upon the topic in 2010.
I got interested in
batteries, and I'll
tell you why in a second.
But when I rolled out this
idea to my wife, to my agent,
to my friends, first thing
I heard was from my wife
over dinner who said
what a boring topic.
Hard B, insulting,
right there in my heart.
And my agent, when I sent out a
proposal to him on this topic,
didn't reply, didn't reply
to several emails, in fact.
And my friends just said,
go do something else.
It was just nothing there.
But if everyone
can remember back
how they felt in
2010, remember, right
after the financial
crash, and a lot of us
were blindsided by the crash.
Almost blew up the
global financial system.
A lot of people lost their jobs.
Remember, this reverberated
after the real estate crash,
after the dot com crash.
And there really
was this feeling,
can the United States
create a real economy
not based on
shenanigans, not based
on a price bubble on an
exotic mortgage instrument?
And there were
really some doubts.
I had doubts.
And remember, globally,
the United States system,
the US system, suffered a
real black eye to this day.
But then especially,
there's a lot
of doubt about the United
States and the US projecting
and exporting its system abroad.
What is this system
that you are championing
that blows up the whole
global financial system?
In that atmosphere,
a lot of attention
came on to the
battery, the whole idea
that you might be able to
take the ordinary battery
off the shelf that we
buy in the supermarket
and create from it a
super battery, something
that would be three,
four, five times as
powerful, and from
that, enable a bunch
of other industries--
electric car industry,
enable solar and wind.
Obama said he
embraced the battery.
We're going to put 1 million
electric cars on the road.
China embraced the battery.
Argentina France, Germany,
UK, one after the other.
And what I discovered--
I stopped at the number
20-- 20 countries.
I started with the big ones and
worked my way down the list.
All of these 20 countries
in one way or another,
either in batteries or
in electric cars, hoped
to own the future of the lithium
ion battery, or electric cars.
Their hopes, all of them
saw some future piece
of a new, real economy would
be occupied by batteries,
or by the electric car.
And this was a big thing for me.
This was an exciting
find, something
that I knew, for example, that
I could sell to my editors
as a story.
But then the other thing that
caught my attention about this
is that if the forecast were
accurate, if batteries did turn
into 10s of billions
of dollar industry
by 2020 or in the 2020s and
hundreds of billions of dollars
in the 2030s, these are
the size of companies
that drive the economies.
This is the size
when you're selling
in the hundreds of
billions of dollars
that a moderate economy
can build itself on.
And for the space that I work
in, which is geopolitics,
I'm looking for how energy will
impact the power of nations,
the wealth of nations.
That was a big thing.
So you could see how if-- name
your country in that group--
really did capture, really
did invent a super battery,
really did enable electric
cars and solar and wind,
you could see how geopolitics
could be impacted.
In 2010, we didn't know what
that shale oil was going
to come upon us,
but look at what
we're watching right now, what
we've seen over the last eight
months.
So we've seen 4
million barrels a day,
4 million barrels a day of
shale oil come onto the market
and cut the price
of oil in half.
As a result, Vladimir Putin,
Russia has been undercut.
OPEC has been thrown into chaos.
This is what I was looking
at in 2010, that batteries,
if you were able
to make this jump,
then you would have
this impact on nations.
One of the things I also
saw-- that captured me.
That captured my attention,
and I wanted to do that book.
Another thing that I saw
was that Exxon, Exxon Mobil,
who produces every
year a forecast,
25 year forecast of the future,
and their outlook, what was
coming 25 years down the road.
So in Exxon's perspective,
in the year at that time,
they were looking
at the year 2035,
electric cars made
up 1% of the sales,
1% of the sales of new
cars on the global market.
And the reason was that between
now and then, over 25 years,
battery scientists would make
no progress, zero progress.
And the same thing when
you little flip the pages
and looked at stationary, at
electricity, solar and wind
had exactly the same place
in the Exxon mobile forecast,
that by the year 2035-- they
use the term intermittency,
that because the sun
doesn't shine all the time,
and wind doesn't
blow all the time,
and you can't store the
electricity from solar
and wind, that in the year 2035,
solar and wind also would have
just this very slender slice.
And I looked at that and I
thought, that's impossible.
How is it possible that 25 years
from now, scientists working
on batteries makes zero impact?
And so what appealed
to me about that
was how the incumbents, the
gigantic incumbents like Exxon
Mobil were taking this gigantic
risk that oil held exactly
its same place in our
society in transportation,
other technologies-- batteries--
made no progress at all.
So I was in-- this was a topic
that I was going to go after.
What I didn't want
to do is, I didn't
want to present it
as a policy book,
as a wonk sort of
survey of batteries.
I didn't want to, for example,
look at every electric car.
I didn't want to do Elon Musk.
What I wanted to do was, since
I understood that there was
a race among
nations, 20 nations,
to make the big
break here, I wanted
to find who is America's
team in this race?
If there's a race on, then
there must be an American team.
And I looked around, and
I found the closest thing
to that, which is at
Argonne National Lab.
Argonne National Lab, it's
one of the 17 national labs.
It's outside Chicago.
This is the first one.
This is where
Enrico Fermi in 1942
made the first self sustained
nuclear chain reaction,
and that led to the
Manhattan Project.
It's mostly a nuclear lab, but
they had-- around the world,
there are 12, 20 certified,
recognized battery geniuses,
and two of them are at Argonne.
Their stuff is in
the Chevy Volt.
So what I could see there is
that this was a place where
they weren't doing
just abstract stuff,
that Argonne had
already commercialized.
So I went over there.
I flew out there.
I did a magazine
story, and it coincided
with the visit,
exactly the same day,
of China's minister of science
and technology Wan Gang.
And so I witnessed the head
of China's battery team,
battery and electric car
team, and America's team
in the same room
at the same time
speaking, and going
around the lab,
and interviewing
the American side.
Jeff Chamberlain, who's the
head of the battery department
and the chief
character in the book,
described the competition to me
at that time, the competition
to be first to make the super
battery, as a battery war.
Argonne, his team,
was at war with China,
and he was at war with Wan Gang.
And I went to Wan Gang.
And I asked him-- and I didn't
use the word war with him--
but I asked him, are
you in a battery race?
Are you in a race with
the United States,
with other nations?
And he said that he was
too, that China was too.
And so the way I frame this
is this is-- I ended up
spending two years in that lab.
I ended up negotiating an NDA,
a non-disclosure agreement,
with Argonne that
allowed me to sit
as a fly on the wall in
that lab for two years
and watch this team attempting
to create the super battery.
And the idea was that
to take ordinary people
into the lives of battery
scientists, people who they
wouldn't ordinarily meet,
and make them understand
what are the challenges.
And so why don't we
have a super battery?
Battery was invented
in the year 1799.
Alessandro Volta invented it.
Why after more
than two centuries
have battery scientists failed
to create energy storage that
allows us to do away
with fossil fuels,
for example, to
store solar and wind?
There are a few reasons
that I discovered,
and maybe this is
the biggest takeaway
that I found when I
was there, and that
was how hard it is to
stuff more electrons safely
into a small space.
We are accustomed after the
lives we've led to Moore's law.
We think that every
year and a half,
the performance
of our technology
ought to double in performance.
The reason we get that, the
reason that chips do that,
is that when silicon
engineers, when
they build the architecture on
a silicon wafer, when they come
back the next morning, the
atoms, the architecture
that they have put
in place at that time
aren't exactly
where they left it.
The opposite with
battery scientists.
So in the book,
what you find out
is that they're
dealing with chaos.
So the idea, what
they're working on,
is to take that battery
that they put into the Volt
and to apply more voltage
to it, to zip it up.
So they're dealing
with 3.3 volts,
and they want to zip
it up to 4.7 volts.
When they do that
at the cell level,
this creates the capacity of
that battery just balloons.
They end up creating
the super battery.
The trouble is, when they try to
scale that up, mayhem happens.
The atoms inside the
cathode in that battery
just move everywhere.
The manganese goes over here.
The cobalt goes over there.
The oxygen up.
And the material utterly
and fundamentally changes
into something else.
The battery scientists find
what they're having to do
is try to figure out how
to make those atoms stay
in the same place, a challenge
that silicon engineers never
face.
And so their challenge
is how do you tame chaos?
One thing, a big realization
that they make partway
through these two years-- and
this happens in the book--
is they discover that everything
they're doing is wrong.
Every avenue that they're
trying to go down,
every path that
they are going down
and that every battery scientist
they know of in the United
States and around the world,
every solution being tried,
at least publicly, is wrong,
and they need to start over.
This is a moment that
I've never heard of.
I know of no other
case, at least
publicly, where a scientific
or a technological venture
basically announces publicly,
because it did become public,
that they failed.
We failed.
We recognize we
failed, and we're
going to start over again.
And the way they
started over again
was-- it goes back
to Steven Chu.
So Steven Chu, the
Nobel Prize winner
at that time, the Secretary of
Energy, and former Bell Labs
guy, he decides that he's
going to recreate Bell Labs.
He calls them Bell Lablets.
He's going to fund them, $120
million each, for five years
to undertake one big task.
And one of these Bell Lablets
ends up established at Argonne.
And the book then
takes you inside
as they go about, as
these scientists starting
from scratch at the
fundamental level,
they discover that they don't
even understand the lithium ion
battery was invented in
1980, commercialized in 1991.
It's been a long time.
They don't even understand
at a fundamental level,
at the atomic level, what's
going on inside that battery.
So they have to start
from scratch on that.
Another thing that happens
in the book, a reality
of technology and science
but especially of batteries,
I don't have to tell you that
technology and science are
a preserve of
exaggerators, hypesters,
folks who claim stuff,
performance breakthroughs, that
are not true.
But batteries are a special
preserve of this fact.
This goes back to
Thomas Edison, 1920s.
He said that when he was trying
to master the electric car,
and he's trying to hire battery
guys who will supply him
with a nickel based battery that
will enable his electric car,
and throws up his hands after
a number of years and says,
there's something about
s rechargeable battery
that turns people into liars.
I sat in that lab,
Argonne, for two years,
finished all that research.
I had written 2/3 of
the book, embarked
on writing the last part.
It's all mapped out.
I know what the ending is going
to be, big Hollywood finish.
And I get a phone call.
One of the main sources on whom
I've been relying, especially
for the big Hollywood finish,
had been deceiving everybody.
He had wildly exaggerated the
performance of his battery.
And he totally
undermined my book,
for one thing, which
is what I cared about.
But he messed up the plans of
a big commercial player, GM.
And also, he
deceived Washington,
the Department of Energy,
ARPA-E, everybody was shocked.
I was shocked personally
and in disbelief.
But this is just reality.
When that happened, it ended
up making, once I recovered
and my heart stopped beating
so fast, this is reality.
This, the fact
that that happened,
made this a more honest book.
So I want to close with just
sort of the book itself, again,
is the story--
you're in this lab.
But I want to just do a
little bit where are we going?
What's going to happen next?
Well What's possible next?
And just very, very short.
So looping back to
that Exxon Mobil study,
so they've produced
another study.
They've updated.
Now they're up to
2040 from 2035.
And it's the same forecast.
The same forecast.
Again, electric cars,
plug-in hybrids, fuel cells,
these all together by the
year 2040 make up less than 5%
of new car sales, all
of them thrown together.
And again, solar
intermittency is this problem.
Solar and wind do
not make-- you end up
with 20 times the market.
But again, they don't make
the big break into the market
because there's no battery
to store their stuff.
So let me give you my take.
First on electric cars.
I think that what
you are doing here,
the self driving technology
that's being developed,
Elon Musk, the construction
of the gigafactory,
especially his announcement that
he's going to have a 200 mile,
$35,000 car in the year 2018.
And simultaneously, GM,
we're going to have the Bolt.
Elon Musk's, called
the Model 3, and GM,
we're going to have the
Bolt in the 2018 model year,
meaning we're going to come
out with it in the year
2017, also $35,000.
This is an inflection
point for the electric car,
and it is for a couple reasons.
One, we don't know what's
the mental switch where
people lose range anxiety?
Is it that they can drive
100 miles on a charge?
Is it 200 miles?
Is it 300 miles?
Is it 350 miles?
We don't know that answer,
but 200 miles is pretty far.
I think that that's
a good distance.
BMW 3 Series, the low
end luxury car, this
is Elon Musk's target.
I am going to go after
those 500,000 people who
buy a 3 Series every year.
I'm going to sell them my Tesla.
Well they're paying the
base price for that car.
The 3 Series is $33,000.
So this means that
in the year 2018,
if Musk can produce his car--
he's been late in the past
so probably will be late
again, say 2019, 2020.
Somewhere in that time frame,
he produces this car. $35,000,
probably after subsidies.
But it means that you,
everyone in this room,
can walk into a showroom
and agnostically
compare Tesla Model 3, all
electric, and the 3 Series BMW
side by side.
You can pick electric or
combustion side by side.
This is the sweet spot.
This is where you want it.
You want people choosing
to drive electric
according to taste.
So I already saw that
as the inflection point
for electric cars.
But now, we have this word.
"Wall Street Journal,"
"Bloomberg," "Financial Times,"
all of them have
reported that Apple
is producing an electric
car, is developing one.
And we have the story
yesterday that they're
poaching engineers, top battery
engineers, and electric car
engineers from A123.
It was a very important American
startup battery company.
It was the biggest
IPO in the year 2009.
We don't know whether Apple
incubates products and does not
always market them, but
they're serious about it.
They've got hundreds of
people working on this car.
I think that if Apple-- I think
it wants to take on Elon Musk.
When you have Musk, when you
have the Tesla facing Apple,
this is its real competition.
This is critical mass.
It's, again, an inflection
point, an inflection point.
That's the beginning of the
electric age on the car side.
And then on the grid side,
on the power systems,
I've been doing a
number of interviews
around here in the Bay
Area with companies
that are creating large lithium
ion batteries for homes--
for your homes, businesses,
malls, factories, and the idea
being that you can cut your
power bill by up to 80%.
They're forecasting that people
go entirely off the grid.
And maybe some die
hards will, but I
think mainly, you
stay on the grid
but you cut your electricity
use by up to 80%.
This is happening.
This is happening
in live time now,
and the forecasts are that
over the next 8 to 10 years,
the grid level storage,
utility storage,
you putting these
batteries into your home
in order to cut electricity
costs, not because you want
to be green, not
because you want
to look good to your friends,
but for financial reasons
that this takes off.
And the forecast,
Citibank forecasts
that this business storage
for your home, for your homes
and for businesses, becomes
a $400 billion a year
business by the year 2030.
This is very, very large.
This is larger than
Exxon Mobil, for example.
And just to close out
in this same forecast,
Citi forecasts that
countries like Saudi Arabia,
like Japan that burn oil in
order to create electricity,
that they install batteries.
They install these large
lithium ion batteries
in their electricity system.
And they're using whatever.
They're using solar, or
they're using nuclear,
or they're burning
natural gas, but they're
storing what they're getting.
They're cutting,
they're peaking.
They're burning.
Those countries are
burning, according to Citi,
4 million barrels a day less
oil than they currently are.
So therefore, global
daily demand for oil
drops by 4 million
barrels a day.
That's precisely the volume
that has caused this turbulence.
It's the volume of
shale oil that's
come on to the market
over the last three years
that's caused this
turbulence, this disruption
in global geopolitics.
And so the next
thing, the last thing
to understand is that this
battery driven age that's
coming, that I think is coming
over the next few years,
is going to shake up
geopolitics in the same way
that shale oil has.
And if shale oil
stays in the market,
if it's not just a
blip, that you're going
to have this compound impact.
And we're going to have a
thrilling coming decade, decade
and a half.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
If anyone would like
to ask anything.
AUDIENCE: So it's
kind of technical,
but I wonder if
you can answer it.
When you were talking about
how the batteries, when they
amp them up to 4.7
volts, that the structure
inside the battery no
longer stays the same,
it's being torn by all these
electromechanical forces
inside, are you talking
about the structure
of the electrolyte
instead of the battery?
Is that the material that's
not maintaining its structure?
It's the cathode.
So in this case, they're using
NMC, nickel manganese cobalt.
It's pretty stable chemistry.
It's, again, it's
the stuff in the Volt
and it's the stuff that GM
is going to use for the Bolt.
And what happens is that the
lithium begins to shuttle.
The lithium leaves the cathode,
goes over to the anode,
leaving all that space open.
And in that nanosecond
when that happens,
oxygen somehow is lost.
They don't know how and why,
but the oxygen-- and they
don't know where it goes either.
But when that happens,
the cathode goes haywire.
And the way that I
explain this is--
the way of looking at this--
first, the thing that happens
is that in that moment, those
molecules-- the manganese
especially, but the nickel too--
become unhappy in the slots
where they are.
And they just start
moving around.
And just for those
trying to picture it,
it's as dramatic a move as
if you drove home tonight
and your garage is in the
attic, and the front room is
in the bathroom, and your
bathroom is in the backyard.
Everything has
changed its place.
And it's so serious
that it makes
the material at that
level-- and that's
the level where you want to
create the super battery.
It makes it unusable.
They need to figure out how to
be able to go beyond 4.5 volts
to juice it up to 4.7 volts
and to make those atoms stay
in place.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So I can see
how a super battery would
have a big effect
on the car industry.
I mean, increasing range,
decreasing weight, et cetera.
But what would the advantages be
for storage for intermittency?
I mean, why can't you
just use lithium ion
that we have right now?
STEVE LEVINE: Yeah.
This is a good question.
You don't need
the super battery.
The battery, what's believed
is that lithium ion batteries
off the shelf that have already
been invented technologically
are there, but their
costs need to be cut.
But that is a challenge you
can do on the factory floor.
Elon Musk can do that in
the gigafactory-- scale
the thing up.
You've got to cut
the costs in half.
But no, you're right.
The technology's there.
AUDIENCE: One of
the other challenges
with a battery in a
vehicle is that you
want to be able to
charge it quickly.
So I have an electric car.
It has a range of about 190
miles, and that's pretty nice.
But heaven forbid I
take this somewhere
where there is no charging
facility available,
because then 110 volt plug
takes just shy of 48 hours
to charge it up.
STEVE LEVINE: You have a Tesla?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
STEVE LEVINE: Yeah.
And how long does it
take to get up to 80%?
AUDIENCE: Well, on 110
volt plug, about 36 hours.
STEVE LEVINE: 36 hours.
And when you're
using a supercharger?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Then it's much better.
Then around like four.
STEVE LEVINE: Four hours.
AUDIENCE: Four hours.
It's not bad then.
STEVE LEVINE: This is something
that they need to address.
What are the challenges?
What are the challenges
of the battery you want?
In your car, what do we want?
Americans, we want to go fast.
We want to go fast when
we want to go fast.
So you want to be able to
get on the freeway fast.
You want to be able to pass
that jerk on the freeway fast.
And then you want to-- I
didn't mean to call anyone
in this room a jerk.
And you want to get
where you're going.
You want to get wherever you're
traveling, 200 miles from here,
and back.
And when you charge it, you want
to be able to charge it fast.
And you want to be able to
do all that without the car
catching on fire.
But habits are changing.
Young people are
driving-- when I grew up,
you were 16 years old, you
got your driver's license,
you had to buy a car.
You had to impress the chicks.
That was how you
did with the car.
And now, young
people, they're not
getting their-- a
lot of them-- are not
getting their licenses at 16.
When they're getting
their licenses,
they're not buying a car.
When they get a car,
they're not driving as far.
And the other thing,
I think, to keep
in mind that contributes to why
Exxon Mobil is wrong is taste.
Over the last, say,
five or eight years,
when I walk into the office,
when I walk into my office
at Quartz, I'm
carrying under my arm
"Wall Street Journal,"
"Financial Times," "New York
Times," "Washington
Post," the print.
I'm the only one.
Everyone else, they don't
say it, but you know.
I mean, some of them say it.
That's disgusting.
What you're doing-- and then
you just throw them away.
You only read them
for 30 minutes.
So in that same way that
my mother, 85 years old,
doesn't get the
newspaper anymore.
This is a big shift.
And a lot of that is a
distaste-- of course,
one thing is convenience.
The other thing is dead trees.
And I think that there is
going to be an inflection
point at which, especially
when electric cars reach
this agnostic
pricing stage, that's
going to be the point at
which-- it's going to start
with young people--
but are disgusted
about the idea of burning
fossil fuels in their car.
And it's not going to be one
of these feel good things.
It's going to be
like newspapers.
normal, not ideological.
It's just going to be like--
for the same reason you don't
throw garbage out of your car.
It just seems alien
that you would do that.
That's what's going to happen.
And it's going to bring
on-- I think it's logical.
I cannot say flatly.
All of these things where
you can't say it flatly,
but I think it's logical
that this happens.
AUDIENCE: So about a year ago,
I was just driving a new car.
And I test drove a Leaf.
And you go to accelerate
on the freeway,
and like you were
just talking, zoom.
In And my what was about an
85 mile range on that car.
And then 10 miles of that range
just evaporated in seconds.
And so I was wondering when
these distances are quoted
when you're saying 200 miles,
or 190 miles an hour-- or sorry,
not in an hour-- 190 miles.
What if you have a little
bit of a lead foot?
Or like you say, you want
to get in the freeway
and you want to
pass, do you still
have that 190 on your Tesla?
And what kind of number?
My understanding
is they're going
to quote the most
optimistic number you
can if you're the most
feather footed gentle driver
in the world.
STEVE LEVINE: But
it's not just them.
I mean, combustion cars
exaggerate the mileage
that they get.
What's the real distance?
AUDIENCE: Well, if I drive it
in a normal way, let's say,
then 190 miles is roughly
what I get out of it.
So commuting, it's fine.
If you really boot it,
then it's around half.
STEVE LEVINE: Wow.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
STEVE LEVINE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But the thing
that's really most notable
is that, for example,
let's say you enjoy air
conditioning in the summertime.
The battery needs
cooling on the car.
So if you exercise any
high performance maneuvers
on the car, the ability
for it to air condition
the interior of
the car diminishes.
So it's another
noticeable impact.
And these are all just
properties of the battery.
STEVE LEVINE: Yep.
Let's go right here.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so
I'm just wondering,
what do you think of fuel cells?
Is it a viable alternative
to the ion based battery?
STEVE LEVINE: So the
question is about fuel cells.
Toyota has decided that
fuel cells are the future.
I'm not so sure.
I know that Wan Gang, this
figure who I told you about,
the Chinese minister of
science and technology,
has the idea of combining the
upside of fuel cells, which
is that they instantly charge.
You can charge them
in three minutes
but somehow have a small
fuel cell and a battery,
have the distance.
And the expense is much lower
for a battery and a fuel cell.
Fuel cells still at this
time cost $75,000 in a car.
So the car, fuel cell car right
now-- the Mirai, Toyota Mirai,
they're selling it for $57,000.
Costs them an estimated
$100,000 to make.
Anyway, so the idea is that you
can somehow combine these two.
A pure fuel cell car, I
think, is an even longer shot
than a battery
driven, pure electric.
But somehow, the jury is out.
Can you somehow combine that?
Or you didn't mention
super capacitor.
Can you install a super
capacitor with a battery
and get that
acceleration so you don't
need as large of a battery?
When you want to lead foot it
to get around the jerk factor,
you can use that juice
from the super capacitor.
AUDIENCE: Question about
the rare earth elements.
Is that just a thing today
and that's not an issue,
or is that a real problem
for these batteries?
STEVE LEVINE: Rare
earth companies
are selling themselves-- or
have been selling themselves--
as an electric car play, which
has misinformed a lot of people
about the role of rare earths.
There's a little bit of rare
earths in an electric car,
but it's really much-- so no.
It's not an issue.
And then lithium itself,
lithium is recyclable.
So one thing that we don't
have with the electric car
is a challenge of where
do we get the minerals.
Cobalt is very expensive.
There is a challenge.
Reduce the component
of the cobalt.
Try to put in more manganese.
So not an issue.
Not an issue.
AUDIENCE: So obviously,
big oil has a lot
to do with the
advances that batteries
can have since they hold
a lot of their control
over the industry.
What are your thoughts
on how that will change,
because obviously, they
have a lot of lobbying power
in Washington.
So a lot of regulations
aren't going
to be set to encourage
further R&D with batteries.
STEVE LEVINE: OK.
And then--
AUDIENCE: I was just
wondering, if you're
talking about using
batteries for power supply,
do they actually take
a significant amount
of their output to produce
in the first place?
Like, how much net yield
are you getting out
of these current
lithium ion batteries?
STEVE LEVINE: OK.
So let me start here.
Exxon Mobil invented
the precursor
to the lithium ion battery 1973
when the Arab oil embargoes
happened, and then
the nationalizations.
Exxon was producing 8
million barrels a day of oil.
With the nationalizations,
that production
went down to just over
2 million barrels.
So it really lost its
confidence that it
could continue at least at
its scale as a going concern.
And it hired a couple
of battery geniuses
from Stanford,
actually, and invented.
And two of them invented
the lithium battery.
But it kept exploding.
It kept catching fire in the
lab, and that was one downside.
And the other thing
that happened over
the years-- this was going
on for several years-- there
was a lot of-- there
was a fever over this.
A lot of people
became captivated
by the idea of what it can do.
And then Ronald Reagan
came into the White House,
and the renewable age was--
the subsidies for renewables
and the research was reduced.
What I'm getting at
is that big oil can
play a big part in this age.
I don't think that it
plays a blocking role.
If this is going
to happen, I don't
think that those
incumbents can hinder it,
even though they-- I don't
think they're quite delusional,
but I think that's the tension.
This is the tension
in the equation.
Is Exxon Mobil right?
Or are these battery guys right?
And incidentally, just to
add one more dimension,
is Elon Musk?
Elon Musk, the
irony is that he's
bet against the battery guys.
His formula is that battery
scientists, the guys who
I profile in my
book, don't succeed,
that the way to create
an electric car,
a competitive electric
car, is to take
the stuff that's off the shelf.
And he uses pretty much off
the shelf Panasonic battery,
a little bit larger
than a double A battery.
8,000 of them are
in the Tesla S.
And engineers-- this ingenious
energy management system
that makes that car work-- and
then designs this incredibly
cool body with every technology
gizmo you could imagine
or ever want, he's bet.
So is he right?
He's essentially bet
with Exxon on that front,
not that the electric
car won't take off,
but he's bet that the
battery guys won't succeed.
Are they right, or
do we get a big leap?
I think this is
the tension there.
If you use-- this
is the question.
Basically, you're asking,
do you end up netting out?
Do you use more energy?
Yeah.
So if you're producing--
if the electricity going
into that battery is from solar,
then there's no percentage.
It's 0%.
The solar, the electricity
produced by the solar,
if you're producing-- and I
don't know the percentage-- how
does that balance out
the natural gas that's
burned to then produce
that electricity that
then goes into the battery
that's stored that then you
use?
I do know that the estimates are
that your electric bill drops
a lot.
But this would be an
interesting thing to get,
right the-- and I would guess
that the less efficient--
if you're burning coal, not only
would you get the pollution.
So the whole process is in vain.
You're creating the same
impact with the environment
that you would anyway, but the
efficiency of coal is less.
The logic tells me
that you would kind of
get very, very, very close to
a loss if you're burning coal,
but not with natural gas.
Is that it?
All right.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]